[Music]  don't you eat the Bluth family shouldn't  foot influences campaign footage you're  running for office really part of the  problem Michael he's finally back  together oh great get dressed up let's  get out of here well that didn't last  long maybe but maybe we can figure out  where it all went home I've made a huge  mistake it seems a lot has changed over  the years I just blew myself for the  first time in five years  well not everything what was it that  brought everyone back together in town  this time but this new new beginning is  different I don't like it because the  Bluths are finally getting the award  they think they deserve could give us  that we're giving it to ourselves  alright it's building this thing like  we'd get the boats because nothing holds  you down like family hi I came here to  save everyone's buster oh look who's  back I thought we were supposed to go to  the chair Arrested Development season  five goodbye forever only on Netflix  [Music]